or just get uh people's dna and then you
know what they're predispositioned to
get injured from or allergic to or
affected by and this is one reason why
the chinese have been doing their
damnest to get as many covet tests as
they can back to china so they could uh
harvest the dna of all the americans and
there's also other crazy incidences
what's the source on that there's this
is the fbi according to the la county
sheriff who came out and said that he's
not going to be participating with the
kobet test because they're linked with
to a company that's connected to china
that is data harvesting and taking
people as dna but we have the source we
have the source i just keep talking like
i got to go julian other things to say
i'm like i'm like
i feel like emperor probably you know
it's just just real quick i want to be
very careful because when we say things
that you know
yes there's going to be a lot of
particularly in this area right
i'm telling you when people listen to
this on itunes or whatever they're going
to be like what npr
february 24th 2021 china wants your data
and may already have it this is talking
about kovid and they they said that okay
as covet cases begin to rise a chinese
company contacted several u.s states and
offered a set of testing labs as a
byproduct the chinese firm beijing
genomics institute would likely gain
access to the dna of those tested
february 24 2021 from all things
considered npr this is as mainstream
corporate press as you get china is
getting your dna yes and when they get
your dna they could game the big pharma
market but also in the in the kind of
levels of uh dirty bombs or biological
weapons they could lead the world in
sending off something on the world that
could only affect a specific amount of
populations with a specific gene
sequencing so the level of warfare that
we're dealing with i would say we are
already at war but information fifth
generational warfare is a lot more
powerful than bullets and steve correct
me if i'm wrong i don't know if you know
about this or not there was also a lot
of crazy incidences reported with
american ships uh nuclear uh ships
literally just being turned off and a
lot of the people not knowing what was
going on only by cyber attacks yes not
just cyber attacks but also just in the
water and then something flies over and
then and then the military ships are
just turned off and they can't uh turn
on there's also some theories about
aliens intervening and stopping nuclear
warfare so there's a lot of different
things out there i'm just interested in
what you've heard about
real quick on that we had we had those
stories about those lights those weird
drones or whatever following the
battleships it's very likely these are
just
this is just technology that exists
or whatever who knows what it is we
don't need specific technology exists
that can disable our what's your
clearance
um
something practical something practical
i think you're gonna see polling that's
gonna come out i think that people are
gonna get in to start polling
and if biden thinks his numbers are low
now
wait to wait to they start pulling
people on do you support going sending
combat troops to the ukraine do you
remember where's the ukraine where is
that again this is this is the uniparty
this is the elites that rule us so far
ahead of the american people because you
know what hunter biden and hunter
biden's kids aren't going to be their
wickers kids are not going to be there
okay this is once again the deplorables
that are going to get deployed to a part
of the world we've got no business in i
think it's fair to say mostly it will be
the deplorables children 100 percent but
but i will say i want to stress there's
going to be a lot of regular poor
working-class families who are going to
suffer from this it's not just the
deplorables
our poor working-class families that's
what i said calling them the deployables
no no but look look the deplorables
was used as a reference to like you know
the people who are supporting the
populist movement trump specifically but
there's going to be you know 100
politically uninitiated regular
americans who working class americans
and the poor and the the sons and
daughters of the poor that's just going
to get so they don't care remember
that you said they don't care no no they
no no no no encourage it no the elites
don't care
what i mean is i would actually take it
one step further and say the elites want
and encourage the poor to be shipped off
to go fight anywhere 100 it's not that
they don't care it's that they revel in
it
that's why people have to stand up and
say no more no moss this is this is
absurd there's an intentional
they want the americans and the russians
to fight so that the chinese take
like uh currency control basically you
think this is the davos i think the
davos have a have this uh hatred because
remember uh the soviet union and a lot
of these cultural marxists and people
that are associated with these things
still
would love the soviet union to be around
they hate putin because he's a
nationalist uh right he's he's very
traditional okay it's a lot of reasons
they sell salvini and a lot of people le
pen and the people in europe you know
like him because he's more or
fine they have an affinity to him
because of his uh his nationalist
tendencies it's one of the reasons the
uniparty hates him and like i said
they're bad guys they're all from the
kgb they're all oligarchs it's
completely a corrupt system right uh
it's a country in a demographic death
spiral
economy the size of new york doesn't
make anything technologically that the
world wants but it's got some of the
best hackers in the world right and so
and by the way tons of nuclear weapons
very sophisticated on december syrian
hackers were actually based in moscow
when the soviet union split did all the
nukes go to russia or most of them go to
russia they go all over the place the
only ones that think that didn't go to
russia were the ones that kazakhstan i
think the guy that the the ruler of
kazakhstan is the only guy that that
really you know turned him into
plowshares right rest of the rest of
them all went back to the uh to to
basically russia they don't think
anybody else got rid of something in
kazakhstan but look the kgb guys are
dangerous but the uniparty hates putin
but that's one of the reasons putin is
uh
is butting up to the ccp now they've got
that unified thing they've gotten and
look we're hitting three
geopolitical crisis at the same time you
have the south china sea and in taiwan
actually have the northwest frontier in
india you've got this nuclear deal with
the iranians that that is totally coming
unwound and now you've got the ukraine
and all these are we're forcing this
we're forcing these except for what we
should be forcing which is taiwan in the
south china sea and we gotta we gotta
that that's that's we gotta take a stand
in taiwan if we lose taiwan what's
silicon valley west what's the northwest
frontier in india that's that's up in
afghanistan that's where pakistan yeah
in the
the himalayas indians and chinese have
been fighting each other for about two
years and by the way i think they're
kind of on i think i what i hear is that
the indian army is a much higher alert
up there than they're letting on
that's been that's a friction point and
think about it the ccp has come down and
surrounded india down in burma right or
miramar with that revolt there so
they're trying to isolate india india is
the key that picks the lock in our
indo-pacific
strategy what happens come you know
trump is do you think trump's running
again i know he's running again he's
going to win again
he's going to win the presidency for the
third time can i say that on youtube
he's going to win the presidency he's
going to win the presidency for the
third time in 2024. well trump is not
the president joe biden is the president
an illegitimate president and if donald
trump runs again do you think
india comes on you know comes and works
we know that modi and trump were good
friends yes and they're both
nationalists and i think that that yes
modi and trump
the biggest event trump's ever had in
the country was howdy modi down i think
it was in houston 50 000 people yeah
right i mean modi and trump are very
close and not just that we're closely
aligned right they he understands that
trump is the one one person has ever
stood up to to to
to uh to the chinese communist party
trump is running in 2024.
trump is going to win in 2025.
i think i i i think your audience heads
blown up
well well as soon as you bring up the
election stuff we are completely
obligated to address it okay we
absolutely have to we'll be deleted off
youtube in two seconds because of
because of that conversation and so
uh what i'll say is i it it's
frustrating for me the the level of
optimism that i you know i don't want to
tell people not to be optimistic but in
2020 and we talked about this in the
members segment uh last time you were
here when i when my skateboarder friends
who work on minimum wage and can't tell
you the name of not even one supreme
court justice let alone define what it
is our posts are making tick tock videos
of them voting by mail and then i'm
going back to like my friends and all of
them are like fervently supporting joe
biden today
some of these people have left the
country
wow so it's i just it's
the the the crew the uh skateboard crew
i i i know a couple people who have
already left the country
and it's not necessarily because they
were like oh no but in so bad it's more
like wow like
this is not a fun place to live i need
to find something better and i don't
think they correlate their actions in
supporting joe biden in 2020 with what's
happening now so i will just stress
in my experience you know we had um
uh i know you and i disagree with this i
want to say tell youtube that tim is
adamant that joe biden won he's been
adamant and joe biden and so it's a
deeply held belief of yours it's it's
look i'm not going to pretend like i
have all the answers to everything but i
will say that when we've had our
conversations with people like like matt
brainerd several times uh there's
there's there's always been uh here's
what we think not here's what we know
and so my attitude is
what republicans have done poorly is
ground game and i'll tell you i think
one of the one of the biggest impacts on
the 20 20 2020 election was universal
mail-in voting not because of any kind
of fraud i certainly think like what
bill barr said yeah there's fraud you
know we don't think there's that you
know is there enough and i've not had
anybody come to me you know you've got
wild wild crazy accusations from people
like lindell and and and sydney powell
but when it comes to the more like you
know we want to do a forensic audit
nothing definitive has come out to the
point where it's been laid out but but i
will say this i want to keep you on
youtube
let's have that conversation in your in
your in your silent behind the wall chat
or some other time because i can walk
you from wisconsin to georgia to
to maricopa to maricopa county not too
intimidating but we'll do i'll get
navarro and we'll walk you through the
whole thing chapter and verse we did
have we had navarro here too yeah
definitely we should we should do a big
conversation but i will say this
one thing to consider absolutely um
first i have my anecdotal evidence being
someone from chicago and knowing tons of
people who uh weren't just the the the
they couldn't tell you what supreme
court justice meant they're like i don't
know what that is and i'd be like okay
well like seriously they don't yeah
these are these are minimum wage workers
they skateboard they don't understand or
want to understand but i'm watching
these people post videos one guy filmed
himself in first person with his mail in
ballot to go and i'm like these people
were absolutely they were locked down
for a year the only thing they ever
heard was orange man bat over and over
again and everything that you're
suffering from is his fault here's what
i think happens
when you have a dense urban population
like new york city where you've got
these big buildings with you know a
thousand people live in it you can get
two democrat activists go door to door
and say see that mail in ballot sign it
fill it out i'll wait but when you're
talking about republican voters in
suburbs or i'll just take that mail-in
ballot and i'll fill it up for you
perhaps but republicans can't do that
you're in a suburb you're going to go
drive door to door the amount of houses
that a republican on ground game could
get to to advocate for universal mail
and voting is substantially lower
substantially orders of magnitude lower
dense urban populations where you don't
need to walk more than 20 feet to knock
on the next family's door whereas in
rural areas you might have to drive
maybe like two or three blocks to get to
the next house that is the level of
ground game that i think needs to be
focused on when they come out and they
say the shadow campaign and here's what
we did i think it's very important you
pay attention to that and keep that in
mind moving into the next election and i
agree with mike cernovich too when trump
came out and started talking about all
this fraud it was effectively voter
suppression because they convinced
people not to go out and vote so i look
at this two ways
we've had multiple people on talk about
this i have not been convinced and we
and and then we've also seen the
detriment to other to future elections
because of the narrative that there's no
point and i think that is something we
need to avoid so that's why i'm kind of
like let's just tell people that's
that's why that's why you got to get to
the bottom of three november you get to
the bottom of three in november you saw
this in in in virginia
we had 95 percent see this is the false
narrative of the left today they're all
on you know msnbc all day they got the
long faces because why we're getting
people to take over school boards we're
getting people to sign up to be precinct
committee men we're getting people to
take over election boards and to take
over the the county clerkships either
volunteer or by voting but you know
democrat all democracy all small d
democrat
and they can't they can't stand it they
have every they have every branch of
government they have the media they have
high culture low culture middle culture
pop culture universities all of it and
they're freaked out because the american
people now are stepping up and doing
this in virginia we had 95 percent
participation in as election officials
and by poll watchers 95 percent in 2020
33 the last gubernatorial race 27
percent the republicans are not going to
allow ever again not with new laws we
don't need new laws but to get to the
bottom of november third and to make
sure that never happens to us again okay
i say it this way remember last last
november in november 2020 we had
sweeping victories across the country
villages in connecticut
miami we had we had we had long island
the villages of connecticut you had you
had the county prosecutor the city
prosecutor in seattle i think we should
definitely do a much longer issue
because i don't want to i don't want to
detract from the news we're talking
about but i do have to say okay when you
see the suburban housewives voting
republican in virginia what was it like
a 30-point swing
they don't like trump man i i think it's
you see this victory for the republican
in virginia when it's not trump but it's
it's a lot of the same but this is also
the orange man bad thing i think it's
over the other thing is people they i
think they can live with mean tweets now
okay
that's what the 26
right track wrong track with the two
hand the right track with the two handle
in front of it it's unheard of yeah
nixon when he when nixon worked across
the lawn and took the helicopter out of
there i think it was 2 30 i think it was
still 33 or 35 percent approval he
wasn't in the 20s
people are seeing recklessness
they're seeing uh incompetence and most
importantly they're seeing that they
don't they don't respect us you've seen
everything that happened on capitol hill
look at this thing with ukraine all
sudden
ukraine comes out of nowhere and in 24
hours we're talking about maybe tactical
nuclear weapons right there's no respect
for the american people to sit there and
say hey here's our plan here's our
policies here's what we're trying to
accomplish here let's let's do this uh
so we we i think we disagree on on only
some but i want to have a conversation
with you we'll do this in the member
segment where you can walk us through
well not centered tonight i'll get i
want to get navarro and take time on
your members section we'll walk through
we'll bring them we'll bring the charts
to the state i think it's something you
guys see graphically but let's actually
go through the details in wisconsin
another thing and people can understand
what we're saying about well i want to
talk about another really big factor and
what's going on today and what also went
down in 2020 and that's media collusion
because we have this tweet from oliver
darcy uh um look hey man shout out to
oliver darcy for actually putting this
out here he said some news in reliable
sources senior white house and admin
officials have been holding briefings
with major newsrooms over the past week
as they try to reshape economic coverage
the white house not happy with the
news's media coverage of the supply
chain and economy has been working
behind the scenes trying to reshape
coverage in its favor senior white house
and admin officials including nec deputy
directors david kamen and bharat rama
rama murti along with port's envoy john
porcari have been briefing major
newsrooms over the past week a source
tells me the officials have been
discussing with newsroom trends
pertaining to job creation economic
growth supply chains and more the basic
argument that has been made the
country's economy is in much better
shape than it was last year i'm told the
conversations have been productive with
anchors and reporters and producers
getting to talk with officials to put it
simply they're having secret meetings
behind your back because they want the
press to change their narrative on the
garbage economy and you're suffering
this is what they did with uh
afghanistan he wanted the afghani
president to tell everyone things were
going just just fine
white houses do white houses do
background briefings to people to make
sure they can understand the
complexities of of issues right and help
the media be smart and want to the
dresses that is not what this is
this is the fact that they have now
spent how many trillions of dollars
on bills that they've passed to juice
this economy
and it's dead if you take the printing
machine away from these clowns this
economy is going to implode and they
know it okay that's why they're up there
today with the with mitch mcconnell and
the republicans doing a gimmick to get
relief on the debt ceiling okay now what
darcy is adding them on is that they're
back now because they got to have the
media work with them to sell it to the
american people remember they're talking
on the talk shows all week the media is
not or sake said the media is not doing
you're not doing a good job of selling
our program
now they need a media partner to sell it
okay because every time you see anything
with metrics like the jobs report last
week which was what less than half of
what the jobs were and people can
remember this is with a massive infusion
of cash
they say it's oh different than last
year yeah you've had another with three
trillion dollars another what two and a
half or three trillion dollars been
juiced into the system okay and yes it's
a lot worse than last year have you seen
this before
i can't i don't know the m1 money supply
oh yeah yeah right there i love it i
love it right around the starts of the
uh the pandemic they they instituted a
change in reporting where they said your
savings accounts are now basically
checking accounts which causes the money
supply to explode by by several hundred
percent but what they and they try and
argue they always say to me tim you
don't understand that huge spike is just
a change in reporting because savings
are now and okay well look at since then
look at this
this spike we went from what do we got
here
16
583 and that's in what billions i think
it is billions of dollars
and now it's at 20 000 billions of
dollars in the span of what we got we
got from june 2020 till october of 2021
we have jumped 4 000 billion dollars in
the money supply
this is fiat money this is the reason
they have forced you i tell people it's
it's you right now every and i'm not
telling you to buy gold and silver or
platinum and i'm not telling you to buy
crypto but here's what i am telling you
you on your own have better get smart on
your own sit there do your study talk to
people because they're forcing you
they're destroying the us dollar in
front of our eyes and they're destroying
you for generations to come if they get
the spending done the seven trillion
dollars programmatically that you can't
take back every person in this audience
under 45 years old you better start to
look for another store of value than the
u.s dollar you either got to look at
precious metals or you got to have to
look at crypto because they've destroyed
it's their this is the machine the
machine right now is out of control and
you can see look let's let's be let's
talk facts look at this gimmick tonight
the one piece of leverage the
deplorables have is the debt ceiling
right they got to come to you and get 60
votes and kind of push the debt ceiling
that they've got you've got them by the
short and curlies and so tonight as we
sit here they've got a gimmick up there
to do it with 51 votes so they they
increase it the republicans don't don't
have to take any hits for it it can go
on they need and remember they can't
sell enough bonds to the to the japanese
into the chinese or to the insurance
companies right they can't raise taxes
taxes all revenues to the government's
around three three and a half trillion
dollars right
they need that huge gap which is a train
a half dollars a year
in perpetuity
plus all these other crazy programs that
are half-baked and they haven't thought
through that comes from printing money
okay and that is on people think it's
free it's not free it's the full faith
and credit
of the united states of america that
would be this audience okay that is on
your shoulders okay and and
that is what's going to destroy us it's
out of control and the unit party takes
care of themselves that's why you have
wicker up there saying yeah we're
thinking about combat troops and
tactical nuclear weapons the uniparty
the party of davos the wall street the
global world corporations and the guys
they paid in in washington dc what do
you think happens to property value
well i think right now that's why i
think look with zero interest rates this
is the scam they have interest rates
artificially low near zero the assets
are increased that's why we had the
concentration coming off of the uh
the crash in 2008 the greatest
concentration of wealth because what
they did they took the balance sheet of
the federal reserve from 880 million
dollars to 4.5 trillion infused it with
liquidity the system with liquidity
assets expi blow up
trump called in 2012 best time to buy
stocks or real estate it's coming right
now the same things happen this is why
we've had this greatest concentration of
west ever
since since the ccp virus and it's going
to continue for the as soon as they stop
as soon as they cut the machine off the
stock market will collapse thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time